[Music]
rebecca is with us hi rebecca how are
you
hi i'm doing great thank you so much for
taking my call sure what's up
all right are you sitting down this is a
big one dave
okay so my husband is a dentist i'm a
nurse practitioner our annual income is
about 330 000 a year um in 2020 i opened
up my own practice with zero debt
because i'm extremely dead adverse i
drink your kool-aid
although i'm not good at following
through i wish i was better um but we'll
get there so um obviously starting out
the practice didn't have a lot of income
with that so we really were relying on
my husband's income
but now i'm starting to bring in an
income for our family so our house
payment is 2800 a month we have over 500
000 in student loans
we have no other debt we've already paid
off over just a hundred thousand but it
has taken us four years to get to this
point we were hoping that by four to
five years after my husband graduated
we'd have it all paid off
but like i said we're not so great with
the the follow through so here's the
deal my husband so let me just tell me a
second let me ask you one clarifying
question okay your practice is now
taking off what does your husband make
so my husband makes we were looking back
what will he make this year will he make
it in a year this year
what are you going to make this year 3
30 is what we're thinking okay and what
are you going to make now that the
practice is moving well i'm hoping right
now i've been bringing home consistently
for about the last three months between
two to five k depending on i just go off
of a percentage of my what do you think
you're going to make in the year
what do i think i'm going to make a
hundred thousand i think you will
and then the next year you're gonna make
150.
uh yes 100 yeah okay that's realistic
okay so you have a 430 000 income
in 2022.
yeah you've never had that before
never so we don't need to throw you
under the bus so much for not following
through in the past maybe a little but
not so much
okay okay i mean you never really had an
income above 200 but much before this
year right no
never so your income's legitimately
doubled this year
legitimate yeah okay good you guys are
that's that's are you ready the good
news is you have a really big shovel
while you have a really big hole
but here's here's the kicker dave i need
this advice because my husband and i are
on different um aspects of this so he
wants to buy into his practice
you don't buy into practice when you're
broke people
okay thank you absolutely not it's
unwise it's not just the dave ramsey
thing it's just it's financially unwise
you can't walk around with your head in
the clouds acting like you have a half
million dollars in student loan debt act
like you don't have any debt
this is a dentist disease
i swear to god of all the doctors i work
with dentists go into more debt than all
of them put together
they go for because for some reason a
dental degree is more i don't even
understand that it is but i mean i meet
a lot of dentists that are 300 to 400 in
student loan debt and then they want to
go another three to 500 in and buy into
a practice or build a practice from
scratch
and go buy all the equipment one of the
two and try to do it all the same time
and walk around acting like where do
they teach you in dental school that a
million dollars is a great thing to be
in debt amount no
no
no no no no you've got time
but you need to lay a foundation
you're going to be very very wealthy if
you do this right or you're going to be
walking around with debt hanging around
your neck with a level of stress
that you can't even breathe for the next
decade because you just won't say no to
yourself
right
i feel yeah i i mean i you can tell
there's two types of dentists out there
when it comes to our material
ones that love me and ones that hate me
there is no middle ground yeah because
the typical model is what your husband's
laying out what he's going right down
the dental school template
all of his buddies are doing the same
stupid butt stuff he's trying to do
he's pointing out to me right now that
he wants me to share with you that his
income is going to increase to 500 2 000
the loan payment's 146 he'll make 357 a
year and that's an extra 37 000 a year
that he'll be bringing home after he
buys into the practice yeah if he
doesn't get sick or there's not a
pandemic or one of the partners doesn't
commit a crime and blow the whole thing
up
right now the only way his crap works is
if everything works and you know when
everything works in this world never
never
it's a freaking optimistic i appreciate
optimism but that amount of debt is
beyond optimism it's fantasy land
okay so he can buy into the practice
later or he can buy into another
practice one thing about dennis is
there's always one for sale
you can always get another one it's like
financial planners with a book of
business you're they're always you can
always get a book of business they're
out there and if he can't buy into this
practice he can buy into another one
later please don't do this please please
please please please please please
listen here's the thing
the reason i'm saying all this is not
just because of debt or something like
that the reason the bottom line reason
this whole thing is
i truly believe after 30 years of doing
this and obviously coaching a whole
bunch of dentists in the process
um that that
10 years from today you will be
wealthier following what i'm telling you
to do
than following what he's talking about
i really do believe that because i don't
think he's factoring in any kind of risk
in his equations
and the only way his stuff works is if
it works perfectly and it never works
perfectly
i mean you've got you've got crazy
people in washington dc you've got crazy
people in the medical community oh sorry
you've got crazy people and you know i
mean out here with the coconut like
coveted stuff and you know you just
don't know what suddenly we're just
going to change the way business is done
in america why we just decided to no i
this scares the crud out of me it just
no i'm thank you i'm so thankful you
were not think about it think about if
you were in this and that
how much dentistry went on during covid
none nine for three months you know yeah
and you know what would have happened oh
my god y'all are acting like you didn't
just come through that i'm just
wondering can this be like a three to
five year goal yeah i mean like well
here's the thing you ought to be debt
free in two years right because i'm like
a 430 000 income you guys could live on
100k and still have 330 to put towards
your debt yeah you got to pack you got
taxes out there but i mean come on lower
your freaking lifestyle stay home yeah
and work and knock this debt out in two
years you should be debt-free and then
save up and pay cash i don't want to
hear about a loan for buying into the
practice just pay cash to buy into the
practice
okay that could happen in five years
that's not a very long trajectory and if
these guys don't want to wait and they
think you've lost your mind then you
probably have the wrong partners anyway
because they're all going to be in debt
up to their eyeballs and run the thing
into the dirt
so
uh dentistry is it's
um
it's as unpredictable as any other
business or industry right now
so no please don't do that i'm afraid i
can't talk him out of it but she was
already talked out of court she just
wanted she's weaponizing the ramsay show
but
it's all right that's all right we we
have we have to be good for something
around here
weapons weapons we can do hey i think
they can get there give yourself some
time
save
a year in debt reduction i mean who can
do that you can do that nobody else can
do that and you can be done in two
freaking years
first world problems this is the ramsey
show